good morning John it's Monday March 8th
let me make this 100 percent
satisfaction guaranteed a hundred
percent are your money back with Z Frank
as my witness I will get a tattoo of dog
poop on this pathetic bicep if I
improved wrong I did not put in a
Nintendo let me outline the specifics of
this argument one at all who wants to
touch dog poop ever in their lives I
have never touched dog poop without
someone else requesting I do it so if I
put poop with a Nintendo it's because
Jesus came and told me to do it or mom
and I cannot imagine either Jesus or mom
tell him you to put poop with a Nintendo
second read Green was a very intelligent
and bad dog when I was in high school I
got a black light because it was the 90s
when I was in high school yeah and I
don't know if you know this but no
matter how much you clean a pee spot it
still glows in the black light well I
got this black light and I brought it
home and over the years red had peed
hundreds of times in my room you know
you clean it up and it starts to get
routine and you don't realize how many
times it's happening but the point here
is that red green pooped and peed over
pretty much every square inch of our
home and it was only a matter of time
before some of the ghan didn't end out
three it is very normal for dogs to
identify important items and want to
mark them and it's clear that the
Nintendo was a very important item in
our house and that was not gonna slip
past red fourth the lady spies left a
comment on your video saying that her
mom's beagle which is very similar to a
dachshund loves to poop in weird places
like on the area of the shower you have
to step over to get out of the shower
and on paint cans and on the vacuum
cleaner
finally the most obvious reason why I
did not put poop in tendo is because it
was not as you say your Nintendo it was
our Nintendo it was my Nintendo 2 and I
loved it and I would never have done
anything to endanger it I mean if you
love something so much you don't want to
put poop in it it'd be like you in the
ninth grade putting poop inside of
Jennifer Wilson you loved her why would
you put poop in her okay so this just
went somewhere I didn't want it to go so
let's just call it a tank
put poop in the Nintendo and we'll move
on to the second part of the video I
went to a friend's house last night and
we watch the Oscars I don't know why I
did that I'm not really interested at
all and the Oscars but several
interesting things did happen one Alec
Baldwin was co-hosting second I found
out that 80 year old astronaut Buzz
Aldrin is going to be on Dancing with
the Stars well you have to wonder will
he do the moonwalk but most importantly
the person whose house we were over at
is an egg farmer because I live in
Montana where people have professions
like egg farmer this is Heather how many
eggs do you get a month oh well I get
about a hundred days so three thousand a
month three thousand a month so when you
have three thousand eggs a month
sometimes you get some abnormalities
tiny egg gigantic egg drama two yolks a
lovely double yolk two yolks in one egg
which is pretty rare and absolutely
delicious definitely the most enjoyable
part of the evening even more enjoyable
than watching James Cameron's ex-wife
kick his ass all over those Academy
Awards and let me just leave you with
this one picture of John and me and
Maggie and read from the late 90s John I
will see you tomorrow